first Jackson Ross this big Jack Co dirt
Brennan swabs got a kid Gator sting in
here for you health in a nice place
acoustic guitar oh now I would send you
guys a video of me playing but the CPU
and Matt - cat instead you know what can
I say shoot or shoot pack shoutout feel
shadow Brennan love you guys
Gang Gang buzz buzz buzz below are the
arms Harvey Oswald fired that cat
shooter shoot alright John Stockman
stupid shooter
that dudes firing huh that's why there's
a little teriyaki on that arrow cat you
feel me what that's a Chinese sauce dude
sauce a little wasabi on that air okay
little ginger uh wasabi little shashka
Juan acoustic guitar bro
I'm a straight man but nothing gets my
dick moist like a nice sound of a
classic guitar bro praise guy here John
Mayer start playing bro my love is pure
dude I used to live with this man for a
while and at night I knew a couple of
songs on the get he'd have me come in
here and play something for him and his
lady he was rubbing down yeah oh really
you know what I could play pretty
decently in college and I would have to
go in there and play him a couple
melodies at night while I fell asleep no
that's cool there's part of my rental
detail part of my detail over there and
I slipped on the couch and I have to
listen to them do sex all the time and
it made me so nervous
but that but your guitar god it made me
nervous your aunt I would get them in
the mood like well if I'm asleep
let me Eric Clapton what zombozo you and
Yvonne I must be strong in carry on cuz
I move you don't be long I don't know
that song what else you getting here in
a pond what else dude bet you play your
body's a wonderland but they're pale
yeah
yeah the net no I would play a little
widespread panic sipping on a tall boy
that would wake them up how's that go so
I'd really just play there cotton went
over and over again I do I love acoustic
guitars silently steel in the dead of
the night I wish you bring the guitar in
here bro oh yeah we'd bring it here man
that's [ __ ] long armed harmonica
brush red city boy they might not even
have been again damn guitar you got four
guitars in two arms dude who are you
fooling Bruff share your [ __ ] you know
there's a lot going on there man be a
share bear you want to get in a cat's
heart you got a share bro get in there
know what I'm saying it's a thing but
she'll kill a pigeon right on your
[ __ ] doorstep yeah that [ __ ] ran out
there and bite its [ __ ] be cuff you
know what to think about guitars the
thing about guitars is you me ugly as
[ __ ] if you play that thing oh yeah
automatically six points like your heart
three yeah guitar 9 yes that Lea Ed
Sheeran
oh no talent can't sing to that guitar
skills Hawk 10 even with his crooked ass
cockeyed
bad bad eyes
damn I'm oh if I can see 360 like
chameleon
he's the ginger Little John brah here's
what I'm saying is I think at Sharon's a
beautiful man dude he's got hair like a
dam he's got hay he's like he's a real
hair aqui but look at him he looks like
something that would swim right up your
penis and if I can give you an infection
but look I'll tell you this man the
guy's got beautiful music goddamn I've
danced with a man I hit one of his songs
once this is the same guy I used to play
music for nope all right this is
together here that man was in the bigger
gals dude I had to go pick him up for
him too I had to drive his truck is he
like do you like him trunk you got a DWI
yeah what kind of chunky were talking
here I'm talking about like Liz oh I'm
talking about you talking Liz Oh are we
talking like Beyonce you ever had too
many McGriddle in a bag and the bag
starts to rip at the top where you
trying to hold it
what what a great reference yeah get
soggy and you know that baddie ain't
gonna hold you gotta hold it back with
your bottom yeah with that bottom man
yeah that's a great reference bro so
just a kind of unique woman her fully
you know fully acclimated to her skin
that's getting about the pop but what do
I know
what are you guys up to these days cat
just in general do you like this man
this white man this musician he seems
like a very nice man he's handsome [ __ ]
together
do you been talking about serenading
some dude for most your life I had to
brown out did you other ways I think I
was in college I was sharing a part with
a 50 year old man it was another college
student have any money you [ __ ] you
think everybody has money that is get
the liver they want so you have to play
music seem to play music to peddle nice
once a week he'd have the lady come over
man maybe twice a week dude I wish you
two brought the guitar
I was just kid with a song did he slip
slip in your DMS cat and play some tunes
I don't know here's what we would love
then I think he should have to serenade
huh or even do a king of sing sexy song
so him play it bro
dude I hear a theme song yeah I say you
serenade are a little Siamese cat over
here and send in a love ballad and we'll
play it on here hell yeah cat can uh can
go it or veto it whatever she wants to
do yeah you better be able to play with
all them goddamn guitars - what's your
Axl Rose what you have so many [ __ ]
guitars what if he works at like the the
the the Music Hall of Fame and he's just
walking out one of the heads good point
you might even play this yeah my artist
his dad his dad maybe Eric Clapton or
some [ __ ]
his dad could have passed away dude well
it's a nice crib too though he might be
a successful musician we said yeah he
does Lee could be success QB and Fall
Out Boy have no idea wife looks nice hmm
hell yeah he looks like CB Dollaway old
school reference well if he wants to
fall out into these Vietnamese for jeans
over here what I'm saying is this dude
needs to tighten up with a sweet
serenade
yeah if you want to fall out and cats
titties go ahead and hit that tune son
yeah yeah yeah those cats are tat
oh sorry cat she's gonna play that in
court one day and when you do that at
the end it's gonna really judge like ten
to fifteen get him out of here
Jesus Christ and you're gonna do it one
more time we welcome as I'm walking and
then as we walk out the bailiff will
reach over and go buzz buzz buzz buzz
keep touching me don't get in trouble
[Music]